and listen systemic racism is a is a
problem in our country and it's plaguing
uh our communities um but it doesn't
stop jay-z
and jack dorsey the ceo of twitter from
hanging out in the hamptons
because racism is real it's real
yeah i mean this is this is jay-z and
jack
um if you look at this picture um
you realize that those are just a bunch
of [ __ ] multi-millionaire
billionaires
out for a little stroll in the house
yeah and you realize that race
is you know it's always an issue in
every corner of the planet but really
what it always is is rich versus poor
because when you get that rich i mean it
just it doesn't exist
the race it doesn't exist because of
billions of dollars so
those people just no matter what your
color when you're that rich
you're just trying to get away from us
and tim dillon you want to just be
as far away from the sushi restaurant
we're going to be at
that's all you want i mean timber
hamptons right now so
what you were just watching is them just
trying to walk away from whatever
store he was just in yeah tim dillon was
in the background of that making a
[ __ ]
video with his with his camera guy ben
about the coronavirus and they're just
politely walking away now tim dillon has
been arrested
in the long island sound off the coast
of connecticut
he has been arrested for fraud so if we
could just pull that picture up
um we don't know we're going to try to
bail him out but they got him
he's he was he was he he started to go
fund me he was a former adviser to the
president
and then he started to go fund me for
the build-a-wall campaign which started
out as kind of a troll move but then
took a lot of private money and
so tim doan has been arrested there you
go he's been nabbed
um yeah i think they got the wrong guy i
think they got jim dylan when they were
looking
for steve bannon yeah i mean we're going
to add to the movie pandemic 2020 we're
going to add to the cast
steve bannon being played by tim dillon
so that's what we're going to do
is we you know you know that's that's
going to be he has to play steve bannon
i mean this is the really the only
choice
yeah if you don't think that him and and
ben from the 70s show
are working on a steve bannon skit right
now in the hamptons you got another
thing cameron
steve bannon's been arrested trump has
distanced himself from that but he got
arrested for fort
fraud him and four of his other cronies
uh are arrested for fraud
yeah one of their uh he was on a
billionaire's
boat uh chinese billionaires both the
china uh
the china guys names uh something gua
guga
his last name begins with the g so i
assume that that's the guy that made the
5g
towers go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild